[Music]
the world that's watching the Chinese
[Music]
are you kidding me or what
uncle Joey watching Bruce Lee the
Chinese connection with my daughter
teaching of the final arts those are
Japanese people merci
I'm telling you I'm gonna turn her into
an Amazon you understand me when you
join karate I'm trying to tell my
daughter when she joins karate teachers
in 1971 you know what to do merci
look at his eyes he's ready to go merci
look at him look at Bruce Lee look at
him with the new Chuck look at the
handsome in the feet watch the noise you
want paint new Chuck's you want paid new
chunks say I want some new Chuck's Jack
that's right block block block there you
go hai block
there you go with a punch I'm trying to
build a savage here ladies and gentlemen
nothing one of these jamoke kids you see
allergic and I listen I took but I
walked the talk you follow I'm safety
fella right daddy we ain't playing games
here I gotta have him watch him Bruce
Lee at this age if not they listen for
the other kids and they think Disney's
everything watch Bruce Lee here jump
fast look at Bruce just look at this guy
watch him here
chum Saint John saying you gotta get
them involved in this stuff now four and
a half
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see I'm saying this is what you got
to show your children not these movies
and not your teacher might defend
themselves - it's a cold cruel world out
there this is how I learned back in the
70s going to see Bruce Lee movies and
get beat up that for the movie and then
you gotta come back next week and watch
it again this time you bring you new
chucks or the roast beef sandwich you
follow me
merci what do you think look at Bruce
Lee see him he's all kicked out he
showed everybody how it's done him on
the way out he put the best words of all
time listen are you kidding me nobody
knows these I lived these movies I used
to go to these movies with the brothers
in Harlem in Union City with the Cubans
and I walk home and you beat up boxes
and you you were looking for somebody a
message here you understand me
my mom he makes them eat the paper
[Music]
that's it for your daily dose of Bruce
Lee I hope your hands learn something
this film here is classic masterpiece up
there with the Godfather Gone with the
Wind all the masterpieces ii Bruce Lee
movie called the Chinese connection Fist
of Fury in China whatever you need to do
[Music]
I'll see you savages in about 20 minutes
at the church the pre Church stay black
say goodbye mercy stay black uncle Joey
loves you remember Bruce Lee for kids
it's a new trend I'm starting it it's
over